drake is pulling himself out of
contention for this year's grammy awards
despite being nominated in two
categories
yeah so drake has withdrawn his
nominations for best rap album for
certified lover boy and best rap
performance for way too sexy featuring
future and young thug now while drake
has yet to speak out publicly on this a
source tells et canada that it was a
discu a decision that drake and
management made the grammys honored his
ask yeah and while drake's reasoning for
pulling out of the race is unclear the
official grammys website confirms his
two nominations have been removed with
no replacement entries meaning both
those categories will go ahead with four
nominees rather than five yeah now drake
is one of many artists who have had a
complicated relationship with the
recording academy back in 2020 he came
to the defense of the weekend after the
weekend was completely shut out for
nominations taken to instagram drake
said the grammys no longer matter
writing i think we should stop allowing
ourselves to be shocked every year by
the disconnect between impactful music
and these awards and just accept that
what that what once was the highest form
of recognition may no longer matter to
the artists that exist now and the ones
that come after
yeah now several fans online are avidly
supporting drake's decision to pull out
of the running with one twitter user
writing fantastic move more artists need
to do this until they revamp the way
they nominate people for awards the
grammys are bogus
all right
well
yeah i i just wanted to say you know the
grammys have undervalued drake many
times in the past uh they undervalue and
consistently misrepresent the culture in
hip-hop as a genre which hip-hop is the
number one genre in the world but a lot
of these establishments are so set in
their old school ways and systems they
haven't actually adjusted to what buyers
are actually listening to and supporting
and i think that drake has the power and
he knows he can produce
change like grammys just don't represent
people well i think the academy needs to
revamp its voting members and actually
make it about the music and just
balancing the genres like before the
grammys were really about the people we
respected the most nominating people it
really was a time where when you were
nominated for a grammy you knew
everybody you ever looked up to was a
part they contributed to you being
nominated so it meant a lot
now there's so much politics and
negotiations like
the award shows in general are just not
what they used to be
um so it's really frustrating for an
artist because from the outside it just
looks like these really cool award shows
but when you're in it and you're in the
industry you know that it's it's really
not what it looks like it's it's
interesting because what is happening
now right what i see now with drake in
the weekend and everybody else when it
comes to the when it comes to the
grammys um when i was young that sort of
like hip-hop world was very small there
was a few artists and these were the
conversations that people who were fans
of rock music had which is the grammys
never represented what it seemed like
the public wanted the the sales figures
and grammys never it never aligned and
this has been a problem with the grammys
forever but the interesting thing is is
that this year they did sort of realign
or reconfigure uh the way that they did
some of the some of the voting but now
you have such a discrepancy because it's
not just sales you have this streaming
number that artists now have in their
back pocket which is individual humans
hitting play on you know on on something
and when you get to those streaming
numbers where there are in the billions
uh four tracks by you know the weekend
and drake and they come up short when it
comes to the grammy nominations the
discrepancy just seems much larger but i
don't know if the grammys have ever
lined up the idea the conversation that
they've always been out off of center
when it comes to what we like to think
that the public is interested in i don't
think they've ever i don't think they've
ever lined up and i don't think they
ever will line up because i think years
ago the grammys sort of thought that
that was cool that it was a little
counter culture even though they were
the establishment they sort of wore like
a badge of honor but it's never going to
match like it's just it's never going to
happen
yeah and and it has to be more about
just sales like it just it's just more
so the representation of it all you know
if someone like adele didn't sell or
someone like bruno mars didn't sell like
people that are the contemporaries now i
still feel like they should win grammys
because we
as a whole um love and respect them and
we know how much they put on the line
with every project and also just the way
that things are behind the scenes like
i've been in the music industry 19 years
right and a lot of these award shows
have are just purely negotiations like
i've seen things happen behind the
scenes that are insane where artists
negotiate how many awards they win they
negotiate who gets opening performance
i've seen big artists say hey i'm only
going to perform at your award show if
you make sure my competitor doesn't get
to perform and doesn't win anything like
shady things go on and record labels
back in management companies back at
whoever's got the most power that year
gets to kind of you know control the
narrative of the award show so it's not
an organic natural real award show it's
a lot of politics a lot of ratings a lot
of nonsense um and a lot of comments um
also that we're getting right now b
being saying drake's net worth is 180
million it'll be fine
vanessa says i think drake is wrong to
withdraw it's an honor to get nominated
um a lot of people are saying a lot of
different things yazi says the grammys
is a business and the rating ratings
have gone down year after year they're
going to have to give in eventually um a
lot of people have opinions and i think
it's kind of split down the middle
whether they agree with drake's decision
or not yeah it's it's interest i mean it
is it's interesting but still you know
as as bad as he you know views the the
grammys was what year was it i was
trying to think of what year it was
when the junos had drake host and they
didn't give a tony awards
give him one award do you remember that
yes and you know what i want to say
about that is nelly furtado
hosted the juno awards and was nominated
for a lot of things and she negotiated
her contract to win almost all of those
awards um whether she maybe she was
maybe she deserved it i don't know i
don't remember but i know for a fact
that she negotiated to win those awards
drake didn't negotiate to win any awards
i think we just assumed he was going to
win most of them because he
dominated that year and the junos pretty
much used him for his name to host the
show and then didn't give him anything
so yeah no he never submits his projects
nobody at his label ovo nobody submits
to the junos just because of that um but
these record these these award shows are
a mess
a mess oh no and you can tell you can
tell they're messy